this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
tmj disorders or tmd are problems with
your jaw joint and chewing muscles
the most common symptom is pain in the
joint and nearby muscles
pain from a tmj disorder may go away in
a few weeks or months with little or no
treatment
if treatment is necessary begin with
simple self-care methods
choose soft foods
avoid wide yawns and gum chewing
use ice packs
learn ways to lower stress
ask your doctor about exercises to help
restore normal movement
over-the-counter pain medications or
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
such as ibuprofen may help with pain
your doctor may also prescribe medicine
to relax your muscles or an
antidepressant
the most widely used treatment is a
stabilization splint also known as a
bite guard
it's a plastic piece that fits over your
upper or lower teeth to help relieve
pain if you have questions about
treatments for tmj disorders or are
having pain in your tmj that won't go
away talk to your healthcare provider
you